what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and still right now
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is all anybody can talk about
right now and right off the bat if you
have not seen doctor strange 2 we are
going to be talking about some spoilers
some big ones so if you haven't seen it
now is the time to click away
specifically what we are going to be
talking about is if wanda is dead or not
marvel studios kind of left that up for
interpretation at the end of doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
and of course they did that on purpose
their whole point was for us to kind of
think that she's gone but also at the
same time not really know because they
didn't physically show her die and the
writer for doctor strange 2 michael
waldron even came out recently and
talked about this in a recent interview
which we're going to break down and of
course talk about the future of the
scarlet witch if she returns will she be
good or will she be evil if she returns
she might be good in her own eyes but
how will the rest of the avengers and
other heroes view her after what just
happened in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness we'll break it all
down in this video and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe and hit
that bell so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos so a lot of the
latest news is talking about how the
scarlet witch most likely isn't done and
even elizabeth olsen is talking about
the future of wanda and the scarlet
witch as well so we could probably
assume that there's a lot more coming
from her but it looks like marvel wants
us to not really know what's going to
happen at the time at least that was
their plan for the ending of multiverse
of madness where one de gore mountain
kind of falls on top of wanda remember
the good old marvel roll if you don't
see them physically die there's always a
chance that they could come back and
during an interview with variety michael
waldron was asked if wanda actually died
or not in which he replied i think
that's up for interpretation she made
some kind of sacrificial act that
destroyed the darkhold in every universe
which is protecting wanda and every
universe from being seduced by the
darkhold whether she's dead or not
remains to be seen i know what it's like
to love characters and to not want them
to be gone and to hate when they do bad
things but that's part of the fun of
watching stuff and getting swept up in
it now here's the deal if you actually
think wanda's dead i'm gonna go ahead
and say she's not typically when marvel
characters die specifically main mcu
avengers characters they're pretty clear
that they die also the actors and
actresses typically talk about what
their time was like playing that
superhero how they're gonna miss that
time how it was a dream come true and
how they're going to always reflect back
on and be super happy about what they
did as that character and how it was
just time to move on this is what
happened with robert downing jr's iron
man chris evans as captain america and
noticed that the characters who are
still around that never really discussed
their fate or future of the character
have all decided to come back mark
ruffalo is back as the hulk in she-hulk
chris hemsworth of course is back as
thor and thor love and thunder basically
when an actor is done being a character
we know and here's the deal elizabeth
olsen has actually been talking about
the future of the scarlet witch recently
and not many people remember this but
kevin feige actually specifically stated
about a year ago that doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness will not be
the last place we see wanda in an
interview with deadline they were
talking about one division and they
asked marvel studios president kevin
feige if there would be an evolution of
wanda storyline through other properties
in which he replied yes to an evolution
of storyline probably and inevitably in
many different capacities and this was
an obvious reference to doctor strange
and the multiverse madness because this
was a year before it came out but check
this out he then went on to say
referring again to doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness he said that's
the first place where that story will
continue but
there will be other places so this was
almost a full year ago in an interview
with deadline and this is the marvel
studios president telling us that
there's going to be other places where
the scarlet witch's story is continued
so it looks like not only is the scarlet
witch not done but the story for her
might have already been planned out and
this actually makes me wonder if they
have planned a one division season two
because something that struck me as
rather odd about multiverse of madness
is that there was not much mention of
vision and we never even saw him not
even in a flashback i don't think there
were any pictures of him i think they
mentioned his name maybe one time when
she said viz and they referred to him in
other times but he really was not a part
of this movie it was all about her kids
but don't forget white vision is out
there somewhere we have no idea what
happened to him we have no idea what his
future story is but maybe that's where
one division two comes into place the
first season was a huge success it would
make sense that they would do another
one and kevin feige pretty much a year
ago was already talking about wanda's
story popping up in other places after
multiverse of madness so you never know
now in recent interviews people of
course are asking elizabeth olson what's
next and every time she talks about this
she makes no mention that she is done as
the character in fact she says that she
is pretty excited to continue to play
the character and excited to see what
stories could come along for her but it
looks like she might have somewhat of an
idea of what could be next for the
scarlet witch here's what she had to say
in an interview with fandango if there's
a good idea i'm happy to play her i also
think her being old will actually be
kind of amazing in the comics her power
kind of deteriorates her and ages her in
a way in some of the comics i do think
of that as being kind of amazing i kind
of imagined myself one day with like
prosthetics and silver hair and like
playing her as this like older wise
woman and so i do have this kind of this
dream of aging her quite a bit i just
really think she's ancient in her like
the myth of the scarlet witch is this
ancient myth and so that's something
that i kind of adore about a potential
future that i'm just kind of throwing
out and i really don't know where it
would go that would be an interesting
storyline but fortunately for us and
maybe unfortunately for elizabeth olsen
i think she's going to be returning
before then especially if you consider
the rumors about her signing a deal with
marvel for multiple more projects this
will most likely include her own solo
feature but will also most likely
include her teaming up with some other
people as well now i don't think that
she'll be playing an avenger anytime
soon because i'm pretty sure doctor
strange is going to have a part of the
avengers right now also wong seems to be
a pretty prominent member of the mc
right now he's been showing up
everywhere and we just got confirmation
that he's going to be appearing in
she-hulk he might have a little bit of a
problem with wanda being a part of the
avengers he was just kind of tortured by
her and plus not to mention his
girlfriend died trying to kill the
darkhold and she killed a lot of a
student so i'm thinking wong's not okay
with her being an avenger however the
darker side of the mcu right now is
being established and definitely the
mystic side is coming out we have moon
knight we have blade coming up and
multiverse of madness truly had a darker
tone to it ghost rider was supposed to
appear in multiverse madness but that
scene was cut and we have the black
knight coming so hopefully the midnight
suns are being set up and hopefully
wanda can be a part of the midnight suns
plus not to mention at the end of doctor
strange 2 in the post credit cleo was
introduced and she says that doctor
strange caused an incursion well wanda
is a nexus being a reality warping being
and it looks like she somehow has
managed to communicate across the
multiverse as she was able to destroy
the darkhold in every different universe
she could always come back to actually
help doctor strange kind of do damage
control on what she caused because let's
face it the only reason doctor strange
had the multiverse jump was because of
the scarlet witch so it is kind of all
her fault so i definitely think there's
potential for her to return in doctor
strange iii however i do think she is
going to eventually get her own solo
movie not her and doctor strange or her
in another character but her own solo
movie and this could be about the
relationship between her and her father
at one point in time in the comics who
is magneto once you get the x-men and
mutants rolling into the mcu this could
be an incredible storyline magneto finds
out how powerful she is and he wants to
go and recruit her for his team but then
of course you would have professor x who
would try to stop magneto and get her to
join him kind of similar to x-men the
final stand with the phoenix force
instead it's the scarlet witch i'm also
excited for the fact that we could be
getting a one division season two there
has been absolutely no confirmation
about this whatsoever yet but the way
kevin feige talked about her story in
continuing after doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness leads me to
believe that they do have plans for her
and right now marvel shows are getting
continuations what if season 2 is coming
and actually loki season 2 is about to
start filming it would make sense that
wanda would get a season two of one
division it might not be called one
division but it's very clear that there
is a lot more of wanda story left
specifically what did happen with that
other vision it looks like we are
eventually going to find out as it looks
like the scarlet witch is not done in
the mcu and elizabeth olsen will be
returning to play her so let me know
what you would like to see as far as the
story is concerned for the scarlet witch
in the mcu let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
me